hello hello Jeremy
is it you I'm gonna be late for work I'm
hanging up
goodbye Jeremy no no no no don't hang up
please
look I'm in the trunk of a car okay um
I'm trapped I'm in a box I need your
help why am I not surprised the first
time we talk in three months you
drunk-dial me no I'm not I'm not drunk I
swear to you okay somebody dialed your
number I'm in this [ __ ] box you're on
a speakerphone okay why do I keep
getting caught up in your [ __ ] Jeremy
this is right where we left off the
gambling is no this is not Morgan trust
me he would not go this far listen to me
please you remember the number remember
the number I gave you in case of an
emergency
yes yes you need to find it me you need
to find it it's programmed into my phone
where is your phone
Jeremy what's going on that's what I'm
trying to figure out okay here's the
deal
find the number call Ben please tell him
what's happened to me and then tell them
they need to secure POTUS in those words
exactly can you do that for me please
okay where is it my computer a desk the
top the top drawer in a folder I am Kate
the desk chores when you moved out I I
don't know Jeremy look I don't know how
much time I have please just find the
number okay
Molly you get it Molly Molly oh yeah
come on babe what